voici diane kruger
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir diane kruger
dia
regard une deux trois bons soirs bon ça
ça va oui tout le monde parle de vous un
mètre est très fière de vous avoir
d'autant plus que vous êtes demandés
dans tous les pays du monde parce que
quand tu tournes pour les routes comme
comme diane après tabac oui la sortie du
film en thaïlande
obligé d'y aller la sortie du film en
estonie tu es obligé d'y aller capitale
de l'est et tu commences pas je me suis
déjà courir semaine dernière je crois
que c'est légal mais j'ai pris le papier
à tallinn estonie
ah si peut-être oui évidemment c'est
peut être qu'ils vont nous répond pas à
l'italie bien la capitale de l'est mais
l'insee la capitale mais si tu reprends
et de la luxure
tu connais jian
ensuite la présenter si tu permets que
david concret genre
c'est vrai que jamais
[Musique]
bungie n'a que des beaux garçons ce soir
avec vos diane kruger donc je vais te
raconter un petit peu la vie de diane si
tu veux bien jeune actrice allemande
avec trois films à son actif qui a été
choisi par hollywood
parmi 3000 candidate pour être hélène de
troie 3000 candidats trois films dans
trois mois la une c'est vrai ok c'est ma
petite fille aux côtés de brad pitt et 2
orlando bloom
quand même ce qui ne gâche rien voilà
faut dire qu'elle est également les
pouces d'un français guillaume canet
acteur et réalisateur dont le premier
film mon idole était extrêmement réussie
qui a bien marché et donc c'est dans ce
film de guillaume canet que les
directeurs de casting de la warner vous
en vous en repérer et c'est un vrai
conte de fées quoi incroyable histoire
jeudi dernier vous étiez en train de
monter les marches à cannes dans une
sublime robe de rome
je veux faire c'est bien bon la honte
avait une robe en cuir
c'est bien à présent des accents je
t'avais dit que ce serait bien je me
laisse très pertinent sur le 2 ça fait
donc dans une sublime robe de karl
lagerfeld en compagnie de guillaume il
vous vous souvenez à ce moment là quand
vous montez les marches à cannes quand
vous êtes en allemagne vous regarder la
télévision et votre grand mère vous
regardez cannes et vous vous dites
asthme enregistré un jour à n'ont jamais
cru d'ailleurs un personne dans ma
famille a jamais fait d'acteurs a fait
quelque chose d'artistique donc c'est
vrai que je n'aurais jamais pu imaginer
devenir actrice tu de vivre en france
c'est fou ce qui vous arrive a vu sa
part le mec et 33 millions d'euros et la
cagnotte du loto ça c'est bon mais c'est
énorme là quand même
c'est extraordinaire 3000 candidate
surtout avec brad pitt orlando bloom
non on va tout reprendre de zéro et
pourtant le match n'ait pas commencé
pippo idiot vous venez là il faut que je
me lance un peu vous venez dalger me
sonne très bien un petit village de la
campagne allemande près de hanovre père
informaticien mère agent administratif
frères qui se cherche
il s'est toujours pas trouvé votre faim
et je pense qu'il va retourner à l'école
donc c'est une bonne chose c'est une
très bonne à prendre sept ans et 25 ans
ça va vos parents diane se séparent vous
avez 13 ans et vous n'avez jamais voulu
revoir votre père depuis aujourd'hui
votre mère vit toujours algarve neeson
non mais elle a repris son nom de jeune
fille colère 1 et quant à vous vous avez
coupé le nom de votre père c'est à ittre
kruger et vous avez décidé de ne garder
que kruger même cru que c'était une
autre guerre diane kruger chaîne alors
première passion la danse vous partez à
londres au royal ballet tu mets une
blessure au genou vous oblige à
abandonner jeter quoi c'était les
ligaments croisés c'était quoi tu peux
pas vous dire en français je ne suis pas
de radio qu'on puisse les examens de
santé cds diplôme tôt voilà il donc vous
vous êtes obligés d'abandonner la world
ans dans quel âge de 16 ans vous devenez
mal qu'un celle it voyage à new york et
ses rafales à la vie de mannequin mais
vous avez toujours quand même ce besoin
de vous produire devant un public
oui ça c'est à dire de mannequinat
c'était génial parce que comme je viens
de la campagne vraiment
allemagne ça m'a vraiment permis de
vivre à paris de vivre aux états unis je
rencontrais des gens incroyables je suis
allé au cinéma a déjà parce que tout y
met à mal
voilà ma famille n'est pas vraiment au
cinéma et puis c'est là vraiment le
désir et n'est que demain ça sera génial
devenir comédienne et voilà un jour
vraiment je m'ennuyais énormément en
tant que mannequin et voilà j'ai décidé
de rentrer à paris
j'ai fait des cours florent et toi
qu'est ce qu'elle orange mais tient la
main je me sens quoique tu te tires la
main bien exercice je me détends un peu
il ya une bonne ambiance ce soir mais
c'est sympa en parle pas de la guerre
j'aime bien donc vous revenez à paris là
vous rencontrer luc besson pour le
casting du cinquième élément dans son
immense bureau et ils vous racontent une
histoire de deux petits vieux en train
de mourir mettait à pleurer c'est vrai
ça non c'est vrai d'ailleurs j'étais
très fâché fâché d'être et milliers de
voix je comprenais pas pourquoi cet
homme que je connaissais pas me
racontent ces choses là et voilà il m'a
dit en partant ce que je voulais partir
il m'a dit voilà tu dois être comédienne
plutôt que maintenant un cd fois la
chute de son histoire s'était pas iihf
dépouille fait pleurer ça génial cette
histoire
vous l'avez compris vous itif between
non pas vraiment mais alors qui est
normal ouais tu l'as compris toi tu te
laisses pendant des années les super
bien alors voilà vous plaquer votre
carrière de mannequin voilà et votre
mère fera aux colleurs et désespérés
parce qu'elle voulait que vous soyez
expert comptable dans un premier temps
dans un deuxième temps elle c'était un
petit peu habitué à l'idée que vous
soyez mannequin mais quand vous lui
dites que vous allez faire de la comédie
c'est bah ouais on était un petit peu
déçue surtout qu'est ce qu'elle doit
être contente maintenant belle et elle
est venue à cannes donc c'est vrai que
c'est très content ah oui j'imagine ce
moment là vous allez au cours florent et
vous êtes au cours florent pendant deux
ans à travailler à travailler tu sais ce
que c'est gérard voilà et vous avez un
premier rôle dans un film de m6 un
téléfilm en suit va vous fait mon idole
de guillaume canet michel vaillant
produit par luc besson et wicker park
que vous tournez au canada et six sur le
tournage de wicker park à montréal que
votre agent vous annonce que la warner
cherche une hélène de troie
hélène de troie la plus belle femme du
monde et hélas vous filmez vous même
dans ma chambre
ben parce que j'ai tourné un film mais
je ne pouvais pas aller au casting à
londres ou à paris
vous faites dans ce cas là ils vous ont
donné des scènes comme des scènes j'ai
demandé un assistant de louis à paris
c'est voilà il ça marche
trois semaines plus tard la production
l'appel ils ont la lumière est pas
terrible on vous envoie quelqu'un pour
vous filmez trois semaines encore plus
tard on vous demande d'aller à londres
pour rencontrer le réalisateur est là et
la productrice trois semaines encore
plus tard trois 3 semaines encore
effectivement vous êtes convoqué par le
patron de la warner à los angeles et là
vous vous retrouvez dans ce mail à moi
vous êtes enceinte un bureau gigantesque
tapis ces deux cartes imagine encore
décrocher un oscar
elle arrive tout petit comme ça devant
le grand patron de la warner il vous
raconte qu'il a casté 3000 actrice et la
trois semaines plus tard à 3 eur puis à
3 r non je fais pas exprès demande à
john cette journée c'était toujours 3
semaines pierre bellemare
trois semaines plus tard on vous
rappelle pour un essai en costume bella
ceux qui sont plus compliquées que c'est
comme un jeu télé là on vous dit faudra
prendre sept kilos en quinze jours et
vous le faites et vous obtenez le rôle
t'imagines son troisième film c'est
incroyable et là il ya un tournage très
très long très très éprouvant qui dure
six mois à londres à malte au mexique
enfin tu vois c'est pas si drôle hein
finalement quand on lit un petit peu là
au revoir parce que quand vous êtes au
mexique et des ouragans obligé de passer
vos journées à jouer au backgammon
qu'elle arrête c'est vrai que c'est pas
ce que je ferai non non mais c'est des
images un peu dur je suis pas sûr que je
faisais quand je préparais à avoir une
vision aussi crevé ouais c'est sur des
détails assez hard jamais tout était
enfermée en train de tout faire chialer
c'est ça être
non mais ça on était deux mois et demi
et j'ai tourné neuf jours dans deux mois
il imagine en plus a perdu un pion c'est
vrai avant mais on était mal de
rechercher dans le sable c'était
quelqu'un
[Musique]